2015 hat die künstliche intelligenz alpha goalie noch monate gebraucht um einen menschen an der schwersten
Strategiespiele überhaupt nämlich ko zu schlagen jetzt schon gibt es die nächste version alfa romeo und diese ki
Also, diese künstliche intelligenz ist unglaublich viel mächtiger. Als ihre vorgängerin alpha. Goalie sie brauchte nur
36 stunden um besser zu werden wie bitte
Also, weil es so fielen beim letzten video viel freude bereitet hat wie ist die lage jetzt bei klicks um science-fiction herzlich willkommen
Immer mehr stimmen warnen vor der rasanten entwicklung der künstlichen intelligenz ki
Space ex kunde und tesla inhaber ihnen macht befürchtet zitat die größte bedrohung vor der wir als zivilisation
Stehen physik genie stephen hawking sagt die verdrängung des menschen durch ki voraus und selbst führende
experten und expertinnen haben sich mit einem wallenden brief an die vereinten nationen gewandt in dem sie
Eindringlich vor der entwicklung autonomer waffen mit künstlicher intelligenz war auf jeden fall ist ki
unkalkulierbar sie kann obwohl intelligent
Rassistisch werden was ist passiert sie entwickelt ein eigenleben sodass sie abgeschaltet werden muss und sie
Überflügelt uns inzwischen mit leichtigkeit und das muss man bei alfa romeo wirklich sagen die software ist so optimiert worden
dass sie wirklich fast unbegreiflich stark geworden ist und das obwohl sie, im gegensatz zu ihrem vorgänger überhaupt nicht mit bisherigen
Kroatien gefüttert wurde alpha wo sie musste also nicht mehr auf mehr als 2000 jahre geschichte
Des ko spiels zurückschauen um es zu beherrschen sondern es hat absolut ausgereicht
36 stunden gegen sich selbst zu spielen nur 36 stunden dann war die software einfach und sogar weltweit
Am besten darin dieses spiel zu spielen auch besser als ihre vorgängerin alpha
Goalie, sie besiegte ihre vorgängerin in 100 spielen zu null also 100 mal gewonnen nun, mal verloren alpha
Bulli war von einem auf den anderen tag nicht mehr weltweit, am besten darin dieses spiel, zu spiel
Und es wird noch besser alpha
Wo sie ist so viel besser dass sie nur noch einen rechner mit vier
hochleistungs prozessoren benötigt bei alfa goalie waren es mehrere mit insgesamt 48
spezialchips also zwölfmal mehr und dabei wurde die software auch noch super kreativ zitat sie erwarten nicht nur
fundamentale elemente der menschlichen grundkenntnisse sondern auch strategien die weit über die spannbreite des
Traditionellen wissens hinausgehen ja so entwickler david silva und noch mal es handelt sich um
Tausende jahre, wo wissen der menschheit die sich diese maschine in ein paar stunden beigebracht hat und dabei den menschen auch noch mit leichtigkeit
Überflügelt hat es scheint dass die skeptiker mit ihren befürchtungen absolut, recht
Mit zwischen ihnen masken mark zuckerberg von facebook ist ja darüber ein heftiger streit entbrannt
Wir haben ja darüber berichtet und es gibt einen punkt den ich ganz wichtig finde und dem nur wenige auf dem schirm haben
Wir menschen sind einfach nicht die schlauesten ihren mast sagt es so zitat das größte hindernis die gefahren von ki
zu erkennen sind diejenigen die von ihrer eigenen
Intelligenz so überzeugt sind dass sie sich nicht vorstellen können dass
irgendjemand dinge tun kann wie sie nicht können
Ja und das ist ja immer so jeder mensch hält sich für intelligent weil er sich aufgrund seiner
Beschränkten intelligenz unmöglich vorstellen kann dass irgendetwas intelligenter sein kann als er selbst alpha koserow hat es jetzt
Bewiesen dass es doch geht ja wenn er mehr zu diesem thema erfahren
Wollt und zu allen anderen themen auf klicks um dann
Lass mir hier ein abo da denn nur dann verpasst er kein video und vor allen dingen
Verpasst sie es nicht wenn mir er mir ein
Denn genau auf die glocke geht nämlich nur dann erhaltet ihr nachrichten
Wenn ein neues video online geht und ansonsten würde ich das nächste video empfehlen dass hier verlinkt ist da geht es auch
um die gefährlichkeit von künstlicher intelligenz unbedingt anschauen und ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran